what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have something extremely
interesting and exciting to talk about
because it looks like Galactus almost
made his debut in Thor love and thunder
Marvel Studios has confirmed there were
ideas for a scene there's even official
concept art of Galactus in Thor lip and
thunder however they scrapped it clearly
because we never saw him in Thor love
and thunder but it was there at one
point in time they were considering
introducing Galactus into the MCU in
Thor love and thunder however Galactus
was not going to fight Thor instead he
was going to fight The Mighty Thor Jane
Foster and it looks like she was going
to possibly fight him alone now we're
going to dive into this and other
deleted scenes as well that official
concept art has been released for but I
just want to say that I am glad this
didn't happen and you'll see in a bit
when we dive into what this scene could
have been but I do believe that Galactus
is possibly on his way there are a lot
of great signs that he is indeed coming
and the Silver Surfer will indeed come
before him so let's dive into these
deleted scenes and talk about the future
of the Silver Surfer and Galactus but
first if you're new we are doing a
Marvel Legends giveaway if you'd like to
enter for a chance to win an item all
you got to do is subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment Down Below
on our videos the winner will be
announced in videos now this official
concept art is coming from Anthony Lee
Nguyen who worked on Thor love and
thunder Anthony has recently released a
lot of concept art he designed for the
movie and in this is concept art that he
created for a Galactus scene that of
course was never in the movie if you
take a look right here clearly this is
Galactus the Devourer of Worlds and like
I mentioned it's just Jane Foster
fighting Galactus he's extremely comic
accurate and I'm sure he would have
appeared to be much bigger in the actual
scene if they would have actually used
him but in this concept art and again
it's concept art there's only so much
you can show but in this concept art he
is not nearly as big as he should be he
when he finally makes it to the MCU he
should be at least as large as a
Celestial and then the eternals the
celestials were so big that when they
came to Earth you could pretty much only
see the head of a Celestial because they
are so big when they get up close you
can't see their entire body but again
it's concept art it's just to show the
concept of what the scene could be like
now it looks like clearly she is
fighting him there's a lot of debris in
the background a lot of broken rocks off
of whatever planet or moon or whatever
she's on and in another scene we can
actually see her fighting through to
break all of these in space to fight
against the mighty Galactus now this
scene would have been crazy cool but I
think most fans would agree that this is
not the proper way to introduce Galactus
into the MCU it's a very very kind of
underwhelming way to introduce the
Galactus because there are a few ways
that this scene could have went down
since Thor isn't there it kind of seems
like this could have been a time where
Jane was simply protecting the Earth by
herself when Thor was off where world we
know that Jane Foster became the Mighty
Thor and there was a little bit of time
in between then and when Thor returned
to Earth and met her again enough that
she came up with according to Valkyrie
several different catch phrases that
never really landed however she does go
on to say in the Final Cut of the movie
that Gore is her first bad guy but it
looks like if some of these scenes
actually remained in the movie we
probably would have seen some sort of a
montage of her fighting off different
beings and different monsters on Earth
while Thor wasn't there because it also
is very apparent that when Thor gets
there and everybody is fighting a new
Asgard when Jane comes out as the Mighty
Thor she clearly knows what she's doing
which means she's kind of done it before
so just a tiny continuity error there
from some deleted scenes in the Final
Cut so this would have been very
underwhelming it wouldn't really have
been made into a big deal it kind of
just would have been a scene between
Jane Foster's The Mighty Thor and
Galactus it almost would have been
played off just kind of like yeah Jane
she fought a bunch of different people
and they just showed Galactus didn't
even mention him who he would be but
they just showed Jane by fighting him
and I don't know about you but that's
not how I want Galactus to be introduced
into the MCU right away right now please
let me know what you think in the
comments down below we're not done
talking about Galactus or the Silver
Surfer but let me know your thoughts on
if this would have been okay or not I
don't believe so but it is very cool
that Marvel Studios is kicking around
the idea of having Galactus show up and
according to some recent reports it does
seem like Galactus is on his way a
report that came out not too long ago
from thecosmiccircus.com states that a
Silver Surfer special presentation is on
its way and that this special
presentation is going to make its debut
before the Fantastic Four movie comes
out so this will most likely come in
Phase 5 or very very early phase six
since the Fantastic Four are pretty much
coming in the beginning of phase six but
the arrival of the Silver Surfer usually
signifies the arrival of Galactus after
all the Silver Surfer gets his powers by
becoming the herald of Galactus and
Galactus shares some of the power Cosmic
with him the silver surfer's original
name is nor in rad and he pretty much
makes a plea deal with Galactus to spare
his world and his people he becomes his
Herald becoming the Silver Surfer
seeking out worlds for Galactus to come
devour so if the Silver Surfer is on his
way to the MCU that means Galactus is
probably not that far behind it is also
worth noting that James Gunn did debunk
a Silver Surfer rumor recently there was
some people online talking about how the
post-credits scene four Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is going to be the Silver
Surfer but James Gunn in true fashion
went online and said that this is false
so don't expect the Silver Surfer to
show up in a post-credit scene in
Guardians volume 3 however James Gunn
has not come out and debunked a Silver
Surfer special presentation granted it
doesn't have to do with the Guardians
which is his project and he may not know
anything about it but he debunked other
Silver Surfer rumors and you would think
that he might debunk that one as well
but the cosmic circus has been pretty
accurate with their reports so I would
expect a Silver Surfer special
presentation to come in the not so far
future but what does this mean for
Galactus is Galactus going to have his
own entire Saga I actually don't think
so you see Galactus isn't technically
and necessarily a villain he is actually
a cosmic balance he creates balance for
the cosmos for the entire universe this
is actually what eternity says and this
explains why other Cosmic beings like
eternity and the Living Tribunal don't
actually stop Galactus in some stories
of course stories change in the comics
all the time the only question is how
will he be portrayed in the MCU is he
going to be a huge threat like Thanos
was or is he simply going to be involved
in maybe one or two movies after all
Galactus has been easily defeated before
By the Fantastic Four and many others in
fact Franklin Richards the son of Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic basically used
Galactus as a puppet Galactus actually
served him but Franklin Richards was
also possibly the strongest mutant to
ever possibly exist in Marvel history
but I'm assuming that Galactus will most
likely be a Fantastic Four villain
probably not till later on down the road
though past phase seven and the reason I
believe this is because Kevin feige
doesn't typically like to go down the
same route that other previous movies or
franchises have gone down so since the
Fantastic Four in the Rise of the Silver
Surfer tackled Galactus albeit very
poorly he might not want to go down that
same path however the celestials were
introduced in the internals and they
were done very very well I love how they
were portrayed I love the size of them I
love the importance of them and Galactus
would fit very well within this
storyline in fact I do believe that
erishim the celestial at the very end of
the eternals could possibly send
Galactus to Earth for their judgment
slash punishment if he deems them not
really worthy enough to live and he
wants Earth destroyed the eternals did
kill a Celestial and they are going to
be judged and ersham also did say that
the fate of the world would be
determined by them as well and since
they killed the celestial it's probably
not going to be that good so he could
would send Galactus to devour that world
the MCU typically does different
iterations of comic book characters to
keep it fresh so who knows what will
happen of Galactus in the MC when he
finally comes if you have any theories
let me know down below but let me know
what you think about Galactus possibly
showing up in Thor love and thunder I'm
glad he didn't but let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
theories for live updates you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf